[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it looks like
the Merc with a mouth will be making his
MCU debut a lot sooner than you think
after last weekend's huge phase 4
announcement that showed the incredible
line of the Marvel have in store for the
next two years many was slightly
dismayed to see that Deadpool was
nowhere amongst the lineup the character
was arguably one of the most popular Fox
properties and during the Disney Fox
acquisition he seemed like one of the
biggest draws Kevin Feige recently
revealed that Deadpool will indeed be
featuring in Marvel projects going
forward though he didn't say whether
they would be standalone or incorporated
into the very pg-13 MCU naturally people
have been speculating a lot about what
could happen going forward but it looks
like today that Ryan Reynolds pretty
much out-and-out confirm that Wade
Wilson will once again be back in a
recent upload to Instagram Reynolds
posted the following photo and caption
which reads investigation heading into
f5 or as I call it phase 5 the point is
I love conspiracy yarn hashtag a leak
over Surrey this is of course a callback
to the infamous Deadpool footage that
leaked and due to positive reception
actually got the foam pushed fully into
production the most interesting part of
the post though is of course the mention
of phase 5 which is clearly a reference
to the MCU so future lineup and it makes
sense that on the anniversary of the
initial leak that Reynolds would
celebrate by leaking the fact that
Deadpool will be returning to our
screens intertwined with more Marvel
properties though this isn't an official
statement to me it seems like Reynolds
would use today the 28th of July to
announce that he will once again be
returning and Disney will no doubt have
massive plans for the character going
forward
Fergie announced that the phase four
panel that mutants would be making their
way to the MCU soon and this was clearly
aimed towards the phase 5 lineup that
seems to be shaping up to include
Deadpool Feige and Disney chief Bob Iger
have both voiced the fact that they'd be
up at him r-rated movies with the
character and for me this is
confirmation that we will be getting him
back
screens sooner rather than later
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this to use and if you're excited to
see Wade Wilson back on the big screen
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you stay locked to the channel
for more breaking news as its announced
if you want to see more comic book
related breakdowns then make sure you
check out my ending explain video for
season one of the boys which goes over
the entirety of the season and discusses
what could happen in the future
I'll leave that linked at the end and
hopefully I'll see you over there after
this and if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I'll see you over
there this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]